do you hope humans become a
multi-politary species
as we're trying to do as a SpaceX is
pushing forward
trialing out to Mars potentially
colonizing Mars colonizing other planets
yeah
I'm you yeah go explore I love the
ambition
of it I love the uh um pioneering nature
I love the extension of what we consider
as our backyard becoming more
four-dimensional
like that
not at the expense of
we still got stuff to take care of we've
got Gardens to tend right here
and sure as hell not to go not to quit
on us to go oh let's get out of here
because this is really working
no no no no no no no
we got a tithe we're still supposed to
pay here we don't that's part of this
pressure testing us as a civilization in
the species
whether you call that restoration order
or whether you call that
let's figure out how to adapt best we
can uh
no not the expense of quitting
here on Earth but we'll let a few a few
select folks explore yeah because that's
like uh guys say go for it please one of
the coolest things that we humans do is
kind of embodies the human Spirit reach
out into the unknown
but it's hard
I mean as Interstellar shows and so on
it's uh yeah as well Elon talks about it
this is not going to be a
weekend Daisy trip
I mean he's just speculating how hard it
could be much harder in different ways
that he doesn't understand yet you know
yeah
well that you know that dance between
the impossible and the inevitable that's
definitely there
with uh what SpaceX is doing what all
the folks
who are trying to become a
multiplicative species are doing it's
really hard
it's like
build rockets that fight off gravity
at a cost-effective way
is really hard SpaceX is close to being
bankrupt several times it's just hard
but it's also inspiring to that some
people are just crazy enough bold enough
to keep trying yeah